hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay we're gonna
gonna go fight a big thing Oh hunger
well that one was dead when I sealed the
pod these things don't die easily
it wasn't gonna hurt me why didn't you
just leave them in there get moving
where'd you go oh okay
I will stop being so bossy
oh the ship is gonna blow up into a
million pieces fake-looking
big whoop
is that that big thing I've heard so
much about
I got a saw you're kind of you're gonna
come yep I knew it
Oh bring it on I got sauce oh damn here
big yeah Oh rip Oh Oh gonna charge me we
haven't seen that before
aah oh honey pop hey okay
gripper not good idea
following up
I see
oh you're in it ah I need help hey help
help I don't have help do i ah guys
stasis him can i stasis him not what I
need to do
alright Huddle's up so I go around
shooting in the back in the back in the
back
oh did I get you
oh you lost your arm there bloody
kicking back
Oh bones you 5,000 credit oh yeah Oh big
boy ain't so tough now I got the level 3
suit so I gotta use that it's like a
time okay
note to self Ripper got so good again
story repeated board if we are under
attack
I'm kidding now are they they've already
killed the next s e-g jury back up here
immediately done you can hold in that
River
Oh better use engineering tools seems
like a better
level three suit booyah I'm just happy
for the extra inventory sighs I don't
know what other kind I don't care it
gives me more inventory and it makes me
look cooler maybe change oh we got a
little thingy on there I guess a few
more plates I can't really tell when
paying that much attention sorry Isaac
you're not that important for me to make
all this there's lots more doodads okay
all right what we got here
that cost 20 times
Oh got so many Ripper blades oh I need a
bench we've got six power nodes I need
upgrade something
how about I upgrade the assault rifle
that you guys love so much
what if I played the rest of the game
with just the assault ring again oh yeah
babe ha ha
just wait till I find you ha ha ha I
should get Chris um and with what what
if you guys do you guys dare me to play
the rest of the game just the assault
rifle write it up in the comments if you
do cuz I'm gonna update it and kind of
leave it as my only choice
no no I shouldn't do that I think I need
more health actually it's more help than
gimme 25 hit poignant takes 3 to get is
that worth it huh I don't know let's see
if I go here pulse rifle I could get
reload and capacity right now how
hardcore would that be oh yeah
what
doing it Oh too late I don't care what
y'all say oh look at that look at this
damn it Hicks pasady one more okay leave
one power node you all hate me right
down don't shift don't scream at your
high touch an idiot I don't care I'm
gonna use it
Oh cuz I'm I'm that hardcore I can beat
the game just do something true that you
know what just to make it more
interesting I'm gonna sell my other guns
sell them well not the plasma
i'ma sell the river how you like me now
hahahaha you hate me hahaha
oh what's that gone oh it's gone hahaha
expecting more fun what fun this way the
crappy is gonna confined
oh I was gonna okay take the crappiest
gun I can find finish the game with it
oh boo yo what am I going
oh right here patreon animators okay
I was like is there an elevator here
okay you guys I'm sorry I just got to
make things interesting
this is mutant you only tried for mutiny
your new kind like to listen to reason
calm down hold him
by maritime law article 54 69 I hereby
declare Captain Benjamin Mathias unfit
for duty it's not too good the marker
must be delivered to the church oh boy
parents yeah brother good call I'm sorry
bender but I can't let you do this
traitor heretic so lose head hold him oh
the hell dude
you just stabbed him in the eyeball then
don't think you deserve that we're
trying to sedate ammunition artery all
right the guy or not good job get
yourself arrested
Oh what's that Oh our own assault rifle
with 150 bullets ha ha I'm so happy
right now I probably shouldn't be cuz I
probably just made the game a lot harder
for myself but I don't care I'm so bad
at I can finish it
oh so good contact beam okay I'll trust
you
hahahaha what oh yeah
Oh stasis ammo whoa oh don't even try to
sneak up on me oh wait it looks like
some of the gravity plating is
malfunctioning
Oh keep an eye up for any kind of
distortion effect coming from the floor
it could be dangerous
okay oh hey hello
that looks like a distortion effect
coming from the floor and it does that
apparently gimme go around it
sneaky see on my diary
oh I'm getting good with this right oh
no no don't stand a chance
Oh loading you up with him I'll go go
jump in one of those lady doodads we go
scream at me baby
your tentacles show me show me show me
all right
that's sucks so bad oh that gun sucks so
bad at those things whatever I got help
that one's still back oh hello you've
been sneaky sneaky you're not so sneaky
I know ball Oh balls
time in half mom know if you're not dead
can't fool me go give me your goodies
nope no goodies give me your goods you
all right stasis there we go
what who's out there
who wants some huh Wow
I can't do I can't do like dad
Oh are you dead you're not dead are you
have no arms at all you did yeah oh oh
power no yes please oh they got they've
got good stuff bring more of them on
want to fight more of them give me like
ten okay I don't look good
I'm guessing I can't walk through that
so probably most problems yeah like most
problems I'm just going to jump through
there what what I'm anyone where am I
going
oh I see I see
stasis omen run still a reckless - okay
ship systems Johnson box rerouted
mmm-hmm making some progress with the
tracking grid uh-huh one of the cabins
give me a hard time
keep moving yeah and I gotta fix it yes
boss I'll fix it boss
there's something back there secret item
secret blood-stained some awesome blood
stain really all right actually I got to
cut it here thank you guys so much for
watching I really do appreciate every
single one of you so thank you for
watching and I will see you in the next
part but I